[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais que je fais je suis pour faire
de bonnes émissions comme un fou j'adore
ce musée moi j'ai des images pour la
semaine prochaine je l'achète coiffure
elle est bien partie dit comme ça c'est
plus ce plaisir vous avez de gagner même
pour jouer comme ça ça marche comme un
fou mais c'est génial ça me fait plaisir
c'est oui alors le mot koussa ponctué
alors l'émission commentaire ça rappelle
une blague ça c'est un mec qui est
bourré je suis dans les blacks battent
avec la grosse rigolade avec moi tu
voulais que je leur raconte je voulais
en plus il y aura un award sur une
blague on passait à battre je vous la
raconte et viable alors à 7 après j'ai
le cadeau pour tout public ça y est vous
à l'équipe et il ya quelqu'un dans les
cafés j'ai dit jacques à l'eau pour tous
puis cassé transforme en charge nette de
manitou
pourquoi alors que ça écoeure jeudi je
récompense le meilleur de tpm fait et
bien sûr le moins bon alors on va
commencer tout de suite par un désolant
à ce que vous préférez
ça marche avec le nez ouais ça marche la
connaît jamais en va non pour le
meilleur man les nommés sont
[Musique]
jean michel lemaire qui semble avoir
beaucoup apprécié la prestation dans
scènes de ménages de mohamed benyamna
plus connu sous le nom du docteur jerry
quelques épisodes avec maquettes et
raymond bachand en fait j'étais là qu'on
l'appelle salle jean michel maire qui a
toujours une belle façon de mettre en
valeur ses collègues et les chinois pang
c'est l'épée pu les plus vrais et
authentiques et cyril hanouna qui sait
comment assurer la femme de benjamin
castaldi
quant à une éventuelle infidélité ne
t'inquiète pas idem que toi tu fais
partie plus enfants au week-end avec
benjamin je peux attester qu'il ne bouge
pas une oreille mais un adc palau en
équipe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
faut dire ou pas qui a gagné selon vous
laquelle de jean-michel la première avec
un problème c'était quoi sur jean-michel
est-ce qu'on peut raconter ce qui se
passe rien sur nous mais en fait c'est
le neuf se régale juste tout seul un
père cela un an d apprendre à les jeter
dans le petit vase labaki à 20 km alors
regardez moi je vous dis on fait cinq
balles partie gens mais c'est reparti je
vais une des balles sorrel wilby hashtag
balle sur twitter j'offre tout de suite
je vous le dis j'offrirai si je le mets
qui je mets une des balles j'offre mon
salaire du jour nasa à un téléspectateur
mais vous changer sa vie
[Applaudissements]
ap ap les millionnaires attention ce
handball
vous allez changer une vie l'affairé
latent qui permettait de bosser je peux
t'arrêter est trop à la vache c'est
impossible à faire
impossible non alors est loin un à cinq
ans il essaie vraiment le faire c'est
celui qui veut se ruiner thébaux il veut
partager
attention le pied là presque un peu
idiot parce que la balle m'a dit
'maintenant pas dit elle cher c'est dur
assez bien
un peu plus haut vous sortez la langue
loin la même base je le sens je le
souhaiterais que les fonds et dont il
faut casser ça je sens et rites et tous
disent intriquées faut casser ça on fait
mais quelle antenne à annuler la
commande de la porte la croix vous
éloignez pourquoi tu m'as si loin non
non je prétendais shaarawy d'accord vous
autorise pas quoi vous changer les rives
en rodage on me rapprocher voire parce
que là c'est trop les deux sexes
allez tu peux le faire celle de tout
faire année au sc bastia les efforts
beaucoup plus fort bah merci
alors on se met d'accord émerger de
balle au tambourin
c'est bien écrit que deux cartons aller
sur les fesses c'est pas mal ces presses
à la mer allez il vous suffit de
balancer la défaite en 6 mètres mais bon
vous ne la fais mathieu
[Applaudissements]
autant
quelqu'un gagne 1 milliard merci alors
on va dire qui tu tu le nom des gagnants
dans un instant quel est le montant que
gagne la personne je veux dire dans un
instant c'est vrai ça va lui content je
vous donnerai le montant dans un instant
et la personne qui gagne attention on a
vraiment le montant de son salaire à
l'émission a bien sûr alors ça date de
l'or ça c'est un scoop
oui enfin à l'heure mais c'est surtout
que ça va lui faire un chat être une
variante bébé incroyable engouement une
boule à moi aussi
[Rires]
toi tu crois pas c'est la prendre avec
la bouche
ben voilà monde cédric c'est la plus
belle chose qui est souvent habillés en
rouge et j'ai remarqué que quand elle
était en rouge a été calme mais dès
qu'elle porte un blouson en cuir
isabelle devient une nouba rld
ah ouais je peux vous dire que quand
elle attaque mais franchement mais elle
le rue dans les brancards vrai devoir
choisir l'insultent la plus violente
d'isabelle morini-bosc josh est bien
accroché
isabelle morini bosc pour une insulte
tellement violente qu on pourrait
l'entendre dans un film de tarantino
mais doit 6 me la question est bien sûr
en doute
[Applaudissements]
isabelle morini bosc qui décidément
connaît bien mathieu delormeau
c'est pénible et phrases avec anicet pas
chier les jeunes et tout mais qu'est ce
que ça peut faire quelques années ça
fait mal et isabelle morini-bosc que
pour une insulte tellement vulgaire que
le csa va encore nous demander 3
millions d'immigrants groulx oui à ma
caisse qu'elle avait un côté lomé
l'autre là c'était alex goude et mamie
qui monte ça va sortait la grande roue
l'appareil qui descend elle et marshall
descente c'est impossible alors dhabi
toi c'est pas moi c'est pas tant la
compote matata temps deux patates sa
mère des friches merguez pois chiches
s'émerveille chiche
c'est une émission pour moi ce soir
c'est ma devise c'est dans mary à tout
prix
exactement alors demain sur sa as
attention vous les sentez les alizés gel
mains antibactérien
attention que vous le tenté de combiner
rayons
moi je la mets ouais tout de suite sur
tout à fait gagner une deuxième personne
trois voitures ont merdé c3 vous mettez
derrière le vieux rêve c'est mieux de se
mettre devant peut-être les plus lourds
trois essais je vais tout c'est vous qui
décidez
nouvel exploit pour les téléspectateurs
c'est derrière il a raison donc le
record de jets en plus il est arrivé à
46 m combien d'essai vous faites c'est
vous qui décidez trois bien trois mois
bon je viens la plume on aurait fait un
beau début d'émission va chercher mature
allait mieux q connaissez pas le changer
tu bouges merci alex tu as bien joué à
cuire pas comme çà ou là bravo l'a pas
fait
sur twitter attention pour gagner le
même cadeau que premier téléspectateurs
hashtag gels mains antibactérien sans
rinçage
le premier gagne un million deuxième
événement trop à droite trop loin je
ferai mon troisième essai dans un
instant à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
et bah y'a d'où ça vient c'est une
machine chérissons du sud qu'ont fait
nos meilleurs médias je vous rappelle il
ya un instant une personne sur twitter a
gagné on c'est à dire du jour j'ai
proposé téléspectateurs qu'il y en a un
deuxième
le jeune était simple pour le faire chez
vous il suffit d'un gel antibactérien
sans rinçage hashtag gels mains
antibactérien sans rinçage
okani elle peut pas jouer il suffit
d'une cuvette
ça va du salat des ménages mais ce que
je veux et la savante 1 100 m² france
c'est très simple jérôme anthony et
trois autres invités aujourd'hui et je
voulais qu'il soit la star il a sa place
on nous a dit oui à 10 où il tue c'est
impeccable exact exact je veux voir le
même angle et non mais je dois prendre
les risques depuis tout à l'heure c'est
dangereux quand même je prends des
risques
il ya un instant je devais faire mon
troisième essai sachez que je ne suis
pas entraîné pendant la pub c'est vrai
je confirme
vous avez réalisé mot fétiche donnait
une personne turin piero sorte est ce
qu'on peut avoir le nom du premier
gagnant s'il vous plaît à s'afficher
c'est sabrina regard sur nous
il y en avoir un deuxième je me lâche je
fais pas tu sais pas confiance oui c'est
normal ça change le poids alors tu
regardes ch dans le visage
non je rappelle qu'il y aura balances
ton poste ce soir émission politique
la salle est très important au tournoi à
12 heures allez on s'adresse tous les
jeux face avant et après la chronique de
série kléber et non chérie qu'il est
payé à l'heure où nos antennes s'agit
d'essayer le pays à l'heure alors à la
wii alors bâtir manacor fonds sont gérés
au soir alors demain soir donc la
troisième édition de la grosse rigolade
l'émission présentée le vendredi soir
sur ses vite et comme je suis un fan de
galéjades et d'humour de bon aloi
j'ai décidé de vous faire élire la
meilleure blague de la dernière édition
de la grosse rigolade
il y aura une blague à près de vous et
moi les nommés pour la meilleure blague
son
laurent baffie de capa et son avis
remarques et des châles [ __ ] je suis
une merde je me dégoûte je suis de la
merde je vaux rien son pote élimé arrête
tu prends palette la tête arrête d'être
culpabiliser comme ça t'es pas le
premier toubib a couché avec une
patiente dit oui mais moi je suis
vétérinaire je trouve cyril hanouna et
elle trouve son mec avec une autre 9
elle va chercher un couteau dans la
cuisine elle arrive bah elle rentre dans
la chambre et le pont mais lui coupe la
tête
elle prend la tête lg passé et la table
se retrouve sur un pare-brise et ya un
père de famille avec sa fille derrière
tu affirmes un maire d'une top sur le
pare brise
c'est relou est tous là un moment il ya
la petite qui fait papa papa c'est quoi
qui assure la voiture rien jamais un
shérif syrien c'est un moustique
mme ellen brosseau est le moustique
[Rires]
et michel boujenah alors c'est de bien
des deux îles à un miroir dans la main
il sait que ça c'est incroyable c'est
d'un là et l'autre élevé mais qu'est ce
qui paraît il aimait 5 ses dunks cette
thèse qu'il soit le quidam qui plat je
suis sûr que je le connais le traité
mais montre moi bien sûr que tu ne
connais c'est moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je m'en fous chez godard je le
connais c'est moi et l'a aidé à tapas
prix du plomb et bien sûr nouveau numéro
de la grosse rigolade vendredi avec
notamment jean marie bigard était bon
voulait franchement c'est du très très
lourd et à bouder exceptionnel au 6 mai
et c'est pas toujours des compléments 1
mais ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu
une émission où je rigole autant l5
danané mission aussi réussi en
production franchement tu en as loupé
tous à celle là elle est exceptionnelle
c'est les inviter aussi exceptionnelle
ces missions est alors j'espère qu'un
jour on en fera une spéciale avec toute
la bande de tpe niveau nous attendait
mais si les mecs qui a arrêté et celle
de vendredi et est folle et je vous dis
merci parce que c'est un énorme succès
ce sera une émission
voilà s'installe au civil bien sûr c'est
un mec qui il rentre chez lui et où à
chaque fois il rentre chez lui et il est
complètement bourré et sa femme à chaque
fois elle le fracasse et un soir il dit
il rentre chez lui il se dit plus cette
fois ci il faut que je trouve un truc et
tout rentre chez lui est complètement
bourré il arrive comme ça
là il arrive dans la maison tout ça sa
femme est fait encore beau est fait mais
n'en fait pas si on regarde tu t'es tu
te regardes tu attends là partout là tu
n'étais même pas mis dessus tu abordes
tu vas pas me croire match jure que
c'est vrai c'est régis et bah on est
rentré en mettrons pas ce qu'on est
basse a tangué comme ça abîme à bombay
dessus bah ouais ouais mais bon je peux
aller me coucher maintenant et mon mari
va te coucher il va se coucher lendemain
matin elle va le voir lui dise que moi
tu vois registre après midi wep ou six
mois tu es dira qu'il a chié dans ton
france lozère
il
[Applaudissements]
ça voulait me to back de jean marie
bigard wii 2 qui va nous faire au
vendredi c'est par là c'est le petit
singe son papa l'a alors va-t-il arriver
au bar et s'agrippe franc-comtois
conseil dit aux garçons vous avez des
bananes et le garçon ait dit non on n'a
pas de man
même si ça j'ai dit vous avez du mal dit
non je viens de vous dire je vais pas de
bananes même 10 1 vous allez bonne à
lignerolles je me demande encore une
fois si j'ai des balles jeudi à l'ats là
et je la clown sur un comptoir dirait
des petits sachets dit vous avez des
clous mais non j'ai pas de clous
alors vous avez des ménages
[Applaudissements]
casting exceptionnel encore mon cédric
alors tout part au poste et une grande
crise à une famille qui accueille
souvent de nouveaux membres des membres
qui viennent une fois et qu'on ne revoit
plus jamais mais je n'ai pas cité de nom
j'ai pas et je pas citer de noms que
vous savez dans une famille en chambre
ou un peu ici ça sent bon et beaucoup et
alors pour le world de la meilleure
relation entre demande de tpm p les
nommés sont
matthieu delormeau qui donne toujours de
bons conseils d'amis à cliver novelli si
vous par exemple on vous voit dix fois
arrivé dans le même bar avec votre femme
dix fois la 11e fauves n'est qu'une
femme qui ressemble un peu mais qui
n'est pas votre femme
les gens vont voir votre femme mais
c'est logique un truc de ouf ce que tu
dis la raison qui perd logique skate
surf et terra cinéma maire de port
[Applaudissements]
non
cyril hanouna qui a toujours un mot
gentil pour valérie bénaïm même quand il
anime une autre émission on a franchi un
paradis mercury je sais faire personne
c'est papa numérique et libido belli
pour sa déclaration d'amitié très
émouvante à jean michel maire il est
très drôle très drôle ça va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu es magnifique et bons mots à moi
peut-être se retrouve alors vous savez
comme je sais que vous avez à peu près
la même carrière que clara et et du
cabaret comme ça je me suis dit on a
fait deux tabourets alors quand on est
candidat en tout cas on va les conduire
à tout le propos est sûr c'est qu'on va
avoir la parole souvent faim pas souvent
fait en gros parce que l'émission est
courte puisqu'elle dure seulement trois
heures souvent les trois ans de plus ce
que c'est que de la té alors chaque
intervention qu'on fait il doit être
parfaite mais heureusement pour le bien
de ma chronique qui a pas mal
d'intervention race et vous allez voir
alors pour le voir de la belle
intervention
voici les nommer
bernard montiel le gars qui passe sa vie
avec des stars mais qui en fait à la
même vie de merde que nous julie sur le
plateau la cpi car toi tu as de ma mère
et à des prêts à rien de lui ni quand je
vais sur ce paris là regardez d'aider
les croustibat c'est marrant compagne et
des picards je suis allé tout à l'heure
sur la santé
matthieu delormeau qui avait
soudainement envie de nous parler de sa
cousine christine ménopausées à 42 ans
quarante deux ans vrai débat c'est sa
part catherine 42 ans c'est fou ça mais
c'est pourquoi c'est très tôt comme ça
oui mais bon vous louiez direct merci
et isabelle morini bosc qui veut nous
parler d'un truc mais on sait toujours
pas pourquoi vous avez des fois les sous
titres en indonésie et donc c'est pas du
tout des gens qui le font en france la
série h par dix ans et oui mais sont en
français mes interventions dont je vous
parle elles sont parfaites en france
mais elles sont en fait des équipes
s'cusez moi il fallait ce type n'est pas
l'avis des sous types les devises alors
je vais reprendre mon nom soit on a
regardé les émissions faisant garde aux
fautes de français
ouais hélas elle redit et ben hocine
maman mais aussi des fautes de français
d'un plein d'émissions mais oui et en
inde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la halle un succès ça aussi la cia
numéro un et ça bravo usa bernard
montiel pas mal quand même
oui ah ouais bah ils changent et pika
sais pas pourquoi alors il est temps
d'en venir au trophée qui fait envie à
tous les chroniqueurs à lusaka connaît
maintenant la batave apparent celui
c'est ce que le plus tacler ses
collègues ces derniers jours musique de
suspense
aujourd'hui c'est le 26e trophée les
tabacs bac est en jeu 26e fc les loups
fait beaucoup d'émissions chaque semaine
est ce que vous êtes un peu moins
assidus vous pensé dans les tacles oui
je pense que nos enfants soient vous
pensez mais aussi non
est ce que le cristiano ronaldo d'état
qui est enfin tombé ce soir le 26e tard
baba est attribué à
c'est vrai que j'avais très peur parce
que beaucoup d'émissions que c'est
peut-être ça va baisser de niveau pas du
tout regardé la première pas suite à des
mots servent à merder parce que cette
andouille elle se veut super écolo et
aériens depuis désastreux pour la nature
de ces bougies là ouais mais jure pas
moi c'est toi moi si je peux me
permettre jusqu'à florent pagny qui
aimerait bien récupérer sa baisse donc
je me ferais tous sélectionnés book
c'est une collection vous oui vous
regardez ma chérie
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
donc c'est du propre
c'était un peu de darron un peu comme
moi alors que là il ya un côté un peu
hipsters enchaîné tous donc du coup
c'est un peu plus sexy on va vous avez
un côté chipster les quatre tournois du
grand chelem nadal l'a fait federer l'a
fait et agacés et djokovic l'a fait
hockey balle en jeu mais jean-louis
alors oui merci en tout cas le
connaissez mieux au pénis comptable mais
pas je te prend directement
voilà bah c'est sûr et certain oui
qu'est-ce qu'il dit guy lux ça va
[Rires]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui aux téléspectateurs ont fait
un anniversaire
j'aimerais ça qu'il a aujourd'hui un an
que je ma chronique avec vous voulez
fêter ça gâteau merci un gâteau surplec
à touba gâteau
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr la tragédie sur la tête la
balle était dans le par les allemands de
l'est
écoutez bien le bruit ça vous prête des
tares lévesque sur mes pas déconner
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
heureusement qui tenir et frère qu'est
ce qui les regarde et un humaniste fo 15
kg et remettez le maïs merci un gâteau
sur le gâteau va bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si didier